exactly as a permutation well a
permutation is essentially an ordering
of objects or items or letters it's an
ordering so we talked about a
permutation let's look at an example say
for example we take the word cat you can
see there's three letters in the word
cat we want to see how many different
ways could we rearrange these three
letters to make essentially a new word
using all three letters so let's take a
look at that you can see that you can
write this as us of course CA T we could
also say CTA we could say a TC AC t t AC
and TC a so you can see there's actually
six different ways of writing this
word using all three letters in the word
cat so there are six permutations or
orderings now there's another way to do
this when you're taking three items okay
and you're wanting to see how many
different ways you can order them you
can use this formula here which is n
factorial now the way the factorial
works is you start at this number here
in this case we're working with three
letters that's going to be three
factorial
and you take that number three and you
multiply down to one so this is going to
be equal to six three times two times
one and you can see there was six
different permutations or orderings now
another way to look at this is
oftentimes this is referred to as the
fundamental counting principle or the
multiplication counting principle and
basically what you're doing is you're
saying for each category here each
letter
how many choices are there well there's
three choices for the first ladder okay
in your word but once you use that
letter now there's only be two choices
for that second ladder and then once you
use up those two there's going to be one
left for the third so it's 3 times 2
times 1
sometimes what your teacher will do to
illustrate this is to have you draw a
tree diagram and so I'll just show you
that real quick so for the first letter
you could choose a CA or a T once you
choose C you've got two choices you
could choose a or T if you choose a you
have two choices that's going to be C or
T if you choose T you have two choices
there's going to be C or a so if you're
going down this branch you can see if
you've chosen C you've chosen a the only
letter left would be T or here would be
C T the only letter left to choose to be
a
a CT a TC TC a T a C and again you can
see if you count these roots so to speak
there's only going to be six outcomes
that are possible going down each of
these roots so that's the idea there now
what happens if you want to take
permutations of n objects are at a time
say for example you only wanted to make
like a two letter word using these three
letters well in walks NPR so what is NPR
well NPR means out of n objects how many
ways are there to pick R of them
okay where the order is important and
there's a formula you're gonna want to
memorize and we'll talk about this in a
minute it's n factorial over n minus R
factorial okay so let's do an example
say we want to make a two letter word
out of the letters in the word cat so
let's just write them out for a minute
so we could have ca we could have CT we
could have what else we could have a C
we could have a tea we could have tea a
and we could have tea C so you can see
there's one two three four five six
possibilities six ways of making a two
letter word where the order is important
so C a is different from a C now we're
going to talk about in just a minute
combinations where the order is not
important and we'll talk about that in
just a second but notice here there's
another way to calculus calculate this
instead of writing all these out we can
use the form you can see out of three
letters C C a and T we're gonna pick two
okay now I'm just using the word pick
just as a way of thinking about this out
of three items you want to say how many
ways are there to pick two where the
order is important so using our formula
you can see that N equals 3 R is equal
to 2 so this is going to be 3 factorial
over 3 minus 2 factorial now remember
the way the factorials work you start at
this number and you multiply down to 1 3
minus 2 is 1 factorial 1 factorial is
just going to be 1 so you get 3 times 2
times 1 which is
6 over 1 which equals 6 different ways
of picking two letters okay out of the
three letters that we started with to
make a word where the order is important
now say for example the orders are not
important so this is when we're going to
be talking about combinations and
combinations you can see that AC okay
and CA these are actually the same two
letters so for example if you were gonna
pick you know two items out of a bag of
three items it doesn't matter you know
if you pick C first and then a or a for
some NC because you're gonna end up with
those two items anyways okay so we would
only count this as one result okay or
one combination same thing here we've
got ta and eight T and then we have C T
and T C so you can see we have grouped
those together so there's really only
three unique outcomes here three
distinct outcomes and the way we would
do this is we would use our combination
formulas NCR and the way this works is
it's n factorial over n minus R
factorial R factorial now notice how
this formula and this formula they're
almost exactly the same right the only
difference is that we're dividing by
this R factorial and what this means is
that we're dividing out the duplicates
we don't want to count a and C and C and
a as the same so what we're doing is
we're you know as different I should say
they're the same so we want to double
count those we want to divide out those
multiplicities so in this particular
example we had three letters okcat we're
choosing two okay that's just one way to
think about it you know out of three
we're choosing to the order is not
important we just want to find out how
many different outcomes there are so
that's going to be three factorial over
3 minus 2 which is 1 factorial times 2
factorial if we expand this out we get 3
times 2 times 1 over 1 factorial choose
1 2 factorial is 2 times 1 notice of the
2 and the 1 they cancel 3 divided by 1
is equal to 3 and that's what we found
out here that there was actually three
groups of those two letters right so
that's the idea between permutations
combinations but quickly I just wanted
to go back here for a moment we were
talking about this formula
the factorials so the N factorial
represents you know how many ways to
arrange all and items so for example if
we had like a word say for example like
math right ma th and we say well how
many ways could we rearrange all of the
letters you can see there's four letters
so we would say that this is four
factorial that's going to be four times
three times two times one which means
there's 24 different ways to use all
four letters and rearrange those and
make you know a different so-called word
right it might not actually be a word
but it'll look like you know like a four
letters right in a different order now
another way to do this problem is to use
the permutations formula the NPR the
only difference is we would be saying
for P four so we'd say out of four
letters we're gonna pick four so
basically all of them and if we use our
formula you can see this is going to be
four factorial over 4 minus 4 0
factorial so I'm just doing the N minus
r but 0 factorial this is one that
you're going to want to memorize zero
factorial is equal to 1 ok so you
weren't going to memorize that so you
can see the zero factorial is 1 so we
end up just with 4 factorial like we had
up here which is 24 so two different
ways to do it I can either use a formula
n factorial or you could use the NPR
formula now if you take a word like
algebra and you want to find out the
number of permutations of all the
letters in the word algebra you can see
that there's one two three four five six
seven letters so there's going to be
seven factorial ways of you know
rearranging all seven of those letters
but notice how that there's two A's so
when there's multiple letters you know
there's a repetitions what you want to
do is you want to divide out those
multiplicities so in this case because
there is two A's we're dividing by two
factorial 2 factorial is just 2 times 1
which is 2 and you can see that if I was
to you know put this a here and this a
here it would still look like the word
algebra so we don't want to double count
that as a distinct as it is is you know
the same you when we wanna count it as a
separate permutation right we don't want
to you know basically treat that as a
different word it's gonna look like the
same words we want to divide out those
multiples right take another example
like Mississippi M is s is
I PPI this one has 11 letters so there's
gonna be 11 factorial ways of
rearranging those 11 letters but notice
we've got four asses so we're going to
divide by 4 factorial we've got 4 eyes
and divided by 4 factorial and we've got
2 peas we're gonna divide by 2 factorial
and again all this is doing is its
dividing out those multiples now you
don't want to make the mistake of saying
4 times 4 this is 16 factorial that's
not correct you have to do these
individually so 4 factorial expand this
out 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
again another 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
times 2 times 1 and just simplify them
and then you can divide and that's gonna
be the number of distinct or different
or unique however you want to say that
permutations of all the letters in the
word Mississippi let's go into some word
problems see if you can do these along
with me here and says if there are 10
people on a committee how many ways are
there of choosing a president vice
president and secretary now at this
point we're just talking about the
number of outcomes we're going to get
into the probability in just a little
bit here but first we want to find out
how many different ways there are of
choosing a president vice president
secretary out of the 10 people on a
committee now the think question that
you want to really focus on is is the
order important or is the order not
important well if you were to take 10
people and you're gonna basically pick
three of them right if you change the
order of those people they're gonna have
a different job or a different position
so the order is important so this is
going to be 10 permutation 3 or 10 P 3
or you or sometimes what I say is out of
10 you're picking 3 where the order
matters now if we use our formula here
for permutations you can see this is
going to be 10 factorial over 10 minus 3
which is 7 factorial and if we expand
this out it's going to be 10 times 9
times 8 times 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 or you could
just write that 7 factorial over 7
factorial you can see those are
cancelling so it's really just going to
be 720 different ways now another way to
do this is to use the multiplication
counting principle or the fundamental
counting principle and you can see that
there's just going to be 10 ways of
choosing a president right but once you
choose that president there's only nine
people left you know in this group to
choose the vice president and then once
you choose those two people there's only
people remaining left to choose the
final position the secretary and you can
then use that multiplication counting
principle with that fundamental counting
principle and multiply those together
you're gonna get the same result a lot
of students prefer this method because
it's just a kind of an easy way to think
about it you say out of 10 you're
picking 3 where the order matters but
for others this is a little bit easier
so let's look at number 2 now it says if
there are 30 people on your tennis team
how many ways can you choose to
co-captains so my question is do you
think that the order is important or do
you think the order is not important
well in this case the order it doesn't
matter because if you take you know this
person and this person and you switch
them they're still going to be the same
co-captains it's not like they're gonna
have a different position like one's the
president ones the vice president know
it they're basically they're the same
position so it doesn't matter you know
and what order we choose them so we're
going to use combinations so 30
combination 2 or you could say out of 30
we're choosing 2 I'm gonna use the
combination formula up here which is 30
factorial over 30 minus 2 factorial 2
factorial so this is going to be 30
factorial over 28 factorial 2 factorial
and again notice this 2 factorial what
this is doing is it's dividing out those
multiplicities like a and B B and a
those are the same two people that are
the co-captains you don't want to double
count those so that's why we're dividing
those out so you can see this is going
to be 30 times 29 times 28 27 all the
way down to 1 right so the 28 factorial
and here we've got 28 factorial notice
that those are the same those are
cancelling over 2 times 1 and you can
see 2 goes into 30 15 times so we really
just have 15 times 29 and that's going
to be the number of ways that you could
choose those to co-captains so let's
look at number 3 it says if a board has
10 women and 7 men how many ways can you
form a committee that contains 4 members
okay so this is important for members
such that all four are men okay so what
do you think on that one so all four are
men well you can see there's seven men
so out of seven we're going to be
choosing four and I'm using the
combination seven combination four
because the order doesn't really matter
it's just a committee it's not
to have a you know president
vice-president or first place second
place third place the order is not
important and you can simplify that
using the combination of formula here
now know a letter B it says to our men
and to our women well again what you do
is you take how many there are in that
group there's seven men but we're
choosing two and there's two that are
women so out of the ten women
we're choosing two and we're gonna
multiply those together so we're using
that fundamental counting principle
we're basically saying you know how many
outcomes there are in this group times
how many outcomes there are in this
group and we're multiplying them
together okay the last one this is a
little bit more challenging it says at
least one is a woman so at least one so
at least means one could be a woman two
could be you know women three or all
four now we could do it you know by
individually and add them all up but
another way to do this when you see this
phrase at least one you might want to
take notes on this one at least one what
you do is you take the total - none okay
what does that mean it sounds a little
cryptic right well the total means how
many ways can you find you know how many
ways can you make a committee of four
people out of 17 people well that's
gonna be 17 choose 4 - the committee's
that have no women on them well the
committee's that have no women on them
would be 7 choose 4 it would be out of 7
man you're choosing 4 now another way
that students like to do this - is you
could say well out of the seven men
you're choosing four times out of the
ten women you're choosing zero but 10
choose 0 just one so one times anything
is itself but this is kind of like a
little quicker way of doing this problem
do the total - no women it would be all
the committees that had at least one or
two or three or all four on them okay
now some examples for with cards playing
cards a standard 52-card deck if you're
not familiar it's pretty easy to
understand there's 52 cards in the deck
half are red and half are black so 26
red 26 black and then it's broken down
into what they call suits for suits
there's 13 diamonds and 13 hearts these
are red and then there's 13 clubs and 13
spades these are black and then there's
a king a queen and a jack they call
these face cards that because they have
a face on them okay in each of the
different suits and then there's
Hubbard cards 2 through 10 in each of
the four suits and then each suit has
one ace okay so let's go into some
examples here it says how many ways
either of being dealt a five-card hand
out of a standard 52-card deck if all
the cards are diamonds okay so we're
trying to figure out how many ways you
could be dealt all diamonds well the key
is you say well how many diamonds are
there there's 13 diamonds and we're
choosing five or you could say thirty
thirteen combination five now it doesn't
matter which way you're dealt the cards
because you can shuffle them up in your
hand once you get them so that's why
we're using the common combinations and
not the permutations so this one's just
thirteen see five how many ways are
there of getting a five card hand that
contains exactly one face card okay so
we look at the face cards you can see
that there's three six nine twelve face
cards so that's going to be 12 choose
one see exactly one face card but then
the remaining cards there's 40 cards
that are not face cards because 52 minus
12 which is 40 and we're choosing four
so one way to think about this is the
first number is how many is in that
group the second number is how many that
you're you're choosing out of that group
and then so you can see here the 12 and
the 40 beds up to 52 the one in the four
adds up to our five-card hand the next
one let's say you want to find out the
number we have not getting a queen so
you get five cards in your hand none of
them are Queens well let's see it looks
like there's a queen one two three four
Queens so if we take 52 minus 4 that's
going to be 48 cards that are not Queens
and we're choosing five okay all our
hearts or all our spades now in math
when you see the word or or means a
union it means both it means like you're
combining all these possibilities with
all these possibilities making sure not
to double count any but in this case
you're not going to get a heart and a
spade at the same time so what's the
number of ways of getting all hearts
well we can see there's 13 hearts so
that's going to be 13 choose five plus
how many ways are there getting all
spaced well there's 13 spades over here
so that's going to be 13 choose five do
those separately and then add
gather okay how about this last one at
most one club so at most means that you
could have zero clubs or one club so
let's figure out how many ways to get
zero clubs so you can see there's 13
clubs so let's just say out of the 13
clubs you're gonna get zero but out of
the 39 remaining cards that are not
clubs you're gonna get five right 13 to
0 is just 1 so I could have just written
39 choose 5 plus what's the number of
ways of getting one club one of the 13
clubs were choosing one and the 39 nine
clubs were choosing 4 notice the one in
the four add up to our five-card hand
the 13 and 39 add up to 52 let's
transition into probability now same
standard deck of cards what is the
probability of being dealt all numbered
cards now a quick review of probability
probability is you know defined as what
the number of successful outcomes so I'm
just going to write the number of
successes divided by the total possible
outcomes okay so another way to think
about it very simplistically is it's you
know how many ways can you get what you
want
out of the total things that could occur
so it's the number of successes over the
total possible right so what is it
probability being dealt all numbered
cards well you can see the number of
cards are two through ten two through
ten two to ten there's there's nine
numbered cards in each suit 9 times 4 is
36 and we're gonna choose 5 of those but
in a fifty-two card deck how many ways
can you be dealt a five card hand that's
gonna be 52 choose five so out of 52
cards how many ways of there of you know
being dealt five cards the order is not
important so we're using combinations
again but our successes are the 36
numbered cards we want to choose five
out of those so number of successes
divided by the total that's going to
give you your probability and this one
what is the probability of getting at
least one ace okay so probably getting
at least one ace means that you could
have excuse me 1 H 2 H 3 s 4 aces or 5
aces right that's a lot of you know
calculation so let's go about it a
slightly different way let's figure out
all the five-card hands that's 52 choose
5
- the ones that have no aces so when you
see at least one do the total - none so
in this case the ones that have no aces
that would be 48 cards that are not aces
because there's just four aces and we're
choosing five okay so this would be all
the cards that the five card hands that
have at least one or more ace in it
because this is the ones that have none
so total - none divided by how many ways
can you be dealt a five card hand out of
52 cards that's 52 choose five if you
simplify that that's going to give you
your probability now if you have some
additional questions about permutations
combinations factorials probability I
I'll put links to some other videos I
did in the description of this video or
another option is go ahead and put your
question in the comments below and see
if you can help one another answering
some of those questions so test yourself
you know by maybe posing a question and
also by trying to answer some other
students questions as well you'll learn
a lot from that also check out my other
videos like I said about permutations
combinations factorials and probability
otherwise subscribe to the channel and I
look forward to seeing you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon